I did Ludwig's roast and then that
spawned into Austin show started doing a
bunch of roasts so that's where you and
I met yes and then I did [ __ ] Camp I did
a Christmas concert I did the streamer
Awards I did a Beyblade event I just did
girls trip I now we're back to [ __ ] cam
when I saw you guys doing the Beyblade
camp or like the Beyblade like thing I
just was like [ __ ] screamers have way
more fun oh my God you could have come I
would have been there in a second yeah
well next time next time plus next time
we'll have the budget to get real
Beyblades which yes yes
that's what people don't understand is a
lot of the big streamers that do these
events like bye or even Ludwig they're
massive yeah they are very big streamers
they get really big sponsors they can
pay for all their events all of my
events thus far have come out of pocket
banking on the idea of like holy [ __ ]
can I get a sponsor like is that how you
monetize like uh-huh so you have to get
a sponsor I was like I was gonna ask
because I don't know like logistically
how it works when there's a bunch bunch
of streamers at one place and everyone's
streaming on their own yeah so usually
that's a really great question I think a
lot of people don't realize it sometimes
I've even been accused of like oh she
does these events for a cash crap fish
if you knew there's no cash if you knew
there's I have not made profit off of
any of my events thus far damn
um but that's fine
um and they're huge events they're huge
[ __ ] ton of people watching this well
and it's starting to get cool because
now I have proof of concept and so now
sponsors are like so [ __ ] camp this year
is 100 paid for that's by a sponsor so
I'm like pump plus profit for you or no
uh potentially I haven't done the math
yet okay
we'll see but I'm more excited about it
just being covered yeah so last year's
ship camp cost me about seventy thousand
yeah
terrifying yeah but we sold merch and we
sold exactly 70 000 worth of merch and
so I was like we've done it you know so
it was really exciting um and just just
so everyone doesn't know what like what
was [ __ ] cam because yes it was super
involved and yeah I don't want to
undermine that part either [ __ ] Camp was
it was four days of 16 streamers all in
a house mostly because I didn't think I
could get them outside so we were in a
house in LA and it had planned
activities from morning to night and
those were all divided on different
streams
um and so it's just like a week of kind
of Big Brother yeah but this year we are
actually outside in cabins in this
current Heat Wave yeah
so there will be deaths yeah yeah
but the views yeah so take that wait
where's the where's the cabin
um it's we're going all the way to
Fresno and it's just like a cabin with
no AC no there's there's AC so these
bougie [ __ ] each of them get their
own cabins and they'll have ACS but
there's canoes this year there's zip
lines there's so we rented out a whole
entire so it's like a real Camp yep
that's sick yeah it's super exciting and
the reason that I was able to do that is
because we did it last year and then a
sponsor saw it and they're like we will
sponsor all of [ __ ] camp but the only
shout outs go on my channel oh so it's
like really oh that's great yeah so I
have
um so out of this year we have 14
streams out of the 14 streams two are on
my channel and those two pay for the
entire Camp that's up that's that's so
sick yeah what was the budget do you
want to say
um the camp itself cost me about 170
000. wow yeah yeah respect damn yeah I
just love this because
um I am definitely the one I like brand
money on fire for ideas yeah mine not
nearly as successful as what you've got
going on but
um yeah I like to be like as transparent
as possible about it like and I even
think I have a community that if I said
like I sold [ __ ] camp for a million
dollars they'd be like that's my [ __ ]
you know like I haven't done that yet
but it's been you know it's been a lot
like this is way better than last year's
and it wouldn't have been possible
without doing last year's yeah
definitely like streamer awards for
example
um that was on credit cards I was like
crazy [ __ ] but then we last like my
contracts for sponsors for stream
rewards streamers Awards was on a
Saturday and I signed my contracts on a
Thursday wow and we Baroque even like
wow I think I might have made 300 which
was very exciting and why like why why'd
you decide to do it stream rewards
specifically I mean just like all the
events like why especially like when
you're taking a risk like that yeah just
like you like organizing
um it comes from a weird it's it's weird
because it it could be viewed as
pathetic I think no it comes from a
weird place where it's like I uh crave
bringing people together and no one else
is doing it and I just yeah yeah it's a
little it's a little oh wait a human
genuine human connection I know you want
to build communities
but it's important there's a huge lack
of it in the streamer space like just
people spending time together yeah yeah
and I noticed because my my friend
Malena she initiated this by starting
[ __ ] Khan last summer and then it was so
great it was just so fun to be together
that I said to her I was like hey can I
do LA's version and do a camp and she's
like yeah please like let's do it we'll
see you three months and I was like okay
and then once I did [ __ ] Camp I realized
like I just enjoy being with people and
as adults you don't get that anymore and
streamers don't show up unless they
benefit in some way like getting content
and blah blah so I'm like forcing my
friends to hang out with me but it works
awesome put the camera on me
Miss give how bad of a person are you
how bad of a person are you you're gonna
reject this genuine attempted community
dick what is he not coming no this [ __ ]
came it's not coming what the [ __ ] it's
okay because he he goes to the Oogie
Boogie bash with me every year so that's
more important if I had to choose
between him coming to Camp or the Oogie
Boogie bash what's that what's that oh
just the hottest event in town
all the cool kids will be there okay you
don't have your Oogie Boogie tattoo I
don't do you yeah
I was like this is you're coming if
you're not part of the Oogie Boogie Clan
then you probably haven't heard of it
um Oogie Boogie bash is a it's a it's a
private event at Disneyland
um Cinderella in my name comes from
the princess I used to work at
Disneyland okay oh we have to talk about
that yeah I have tons of stories
um but Oogie Boogie bash is a private
event it's the one time of year that
they allow adults to wear costumes
interesting um and it's like after hours
so the line's really short you do
trick-or-treating and stuff like that
and Ms Kiff and I went last year he was
Buzz Lightyear and I was Woody how do
you get invited to that oh you you can
buy tickets it's not actually okay like
it's just like they close down the rest
of the park besides people that bought
these specific event tickets
um so you just have to buy tickets this
year I bought
six two tickets to three different days
because I was like oh it's gonna be
great yeah so I'm just gonna slowly take
more and more people to Oogie Boogie
bash damn you really are about just
bringing people together I just want to
hang out with you I just want friends
that's a lot no that's super sick no
that's actually a really good point that
I was talking to lean about this
recently or I was thinking Jesus Christ
you think about when you were 22 and it
was all it just at any point you could
call four or five people and just you
know go hang out somewhere well because
chances are you lived with them I mean
it's it either lived with or close yeah
any of that and just that that's the
shittiest part I think about getting
older is this 100 yeah we were just
talking about that too with or I was
talking with Kelsey about it because our
friends just did like their second
annual costume party yeah where in July
they just like hosted a costume party
last year and then this year they like
did it again and then we were talking to
another friend and he was like yeah we
we do this steak weekend and we made it
an annual thing and I was like we need
an annual thing because if we don't have
one yeah we're gonna be the only people
that don't invite people to and that's
so important as you get older yeah yeah
because you don't see your friends
anymore thanks for the existential
Christ you're welcome yeah you're
welcome yeah I have uh something like
once a month at this point in my life
like because I just sick and no one else
was was doing it and no one else was
bringing it like my favorite thing about
[ __ ] Camp last year all the streams are
off it was just all of us in a room
watching squid games nice like that was
it and that was my favorite part getting
to know these people like I don't know
because these are like these are our
version of co-workers like some of my
best friends I've met in life have been
like that person you were in class with
or your co-workers and this job is so
isolating yeah
um because it's very superficial too
there's a superficial part of streaming
there's like you know a lot of social
climbing and all this stuff and it's
just like how do you dude I'm happy you
said it
oh [ __ ]